Speaker 1: We are taking calls a day early
because we I'm going to be traveling and a
lot of different, you know, things are going on
and it's all crazy. Let's go next to Chris from
Maine who says that he has fixed his microphone as
well. Hello. Can you hear me? Yes, I can, Chris.
Speaker 2: OK, I have a question for
you. What do you think will happen
when Trump will not get reinstated in an August,
which it now is? Yes. Well, what do you think the
Michael and the Trump will do?
Speaker 1: I think that
a few of them will try to get some kind of
violent thing going. They may succeed or
they may not. Most of them will do nothing and
many will become fixated on some new date at
which something is supposedly going to happen.
Speaker 2: OK, and one more question for you.
Yeah, what do you what do you think would happen
if Trent ran in twenty twenty four and then had
run the Santurce as far as his running mate?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I think that that
would be right now. I would say that gives him
a better shot than running alongside Mike Pence.
But as I mentioned to the caller earlier, I don't
know that Trump's ego lets him have someone like
DeSantis who's much less of a second fiddle,
the way Mike Mike Pence was basically a plant.
Sometimes it was almost like is is that a lemon
tree or is that Mike Pence in the background
there? And Rhonda Santurce isn't like that.
And Trump needs a real Beda to use their word
behind him. So that's what makes me doubt Trump
would pick the Santurce as his running mate.
OK, thank you. I'm curious how old a guy are you?
Speaker 2: I am I am 15.
Speaker 1: I thought so, OK. That's that's it's
great that you're following what's going on in the
world. I think that that's a really great thing,
Chris. Yeah. Thank you. All right. There's Chris
remained the most coherent caller of the day and
only 15 years old, if you can believe it. Just so
people know, everybody who's waiting to get on and
all that shows up is like a nickname you're not
getting on. So if you want if you want a chance
at talking to me, it has to say name and town. OK,
so there's a lot of nicknames. There's zero
chance you're getting on if that's what you have.